hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the pesticide Explorer
collection multi residue pesticide
analysis made easy for the routine
laboratory I am Brenda Kelly Kim from
libraries and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational read seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific thermo fisher
scientific is a world leader in serving
science whose mission is to enable
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer thermo fisher
scientific helps their customers
accelerate life sciences research solve
complex analytical challenges improve
patient diagnostics and increase
laboratory productivity for more
information please visit www m we have a
few announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit your
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation properly
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problems through
the green Q&A button lower left would
now like to introduce today's speakers
katerina bolshevik studied food
chemistry and chemical analysis faculty
of food and biochemical technology at
the institute of chemical technology and
products and finished her master's
degrees in 2006 from 2006 to 2010 she
worked as a chemical analyst at the
department of chemistry at the State
Veterinary Institute in Prague in 2010
thermo fisher scientific established a
new laboratory food safety response
center in four is germany where Catalina
started working as an application
specialist she was a member of a small
which focused on the rapid development
of analytical methods to respond to
emerging contaminations input in 2013
the name of the group has changed
special solution Center and the field
activity has broadened Katrina is still
responsible for developments and new
analytical methods but it's also giving
the presentation about new trends and
food safety areas giving trainings for
customers and preparing various
workshops in the area of testing ed
George as a BS in chemistry from the
University of Notre Dame with a
concentration in environmental science
we work for 15 years in the commercial
environmental laboratory industry he
participated in several collaborative
method development projects with the US
EPA in 2005 to 2009 he worked for
variant incorporated as an application
lab manager developing applications for
pesticide residues in food and water
from major major product launches in ion
trap triple quadrupole ms systems adjoin
brokered all tronox in january 2010 as
an application chemist and later became
product manager to the scion single
quadrupole instrument responsible for
product marketing definition and
implementation acquiring voice of
customer feedback for product feature
input competitive analysis sales
training global sense seminars for
dealers inside sales and margin analysis
ed is currently senior application
scientists at thermo fisher scientific
supporting the life science mass
spectrometry group for environmental and
food safety analysis i will now turn it
over to Katerina for the first part of
the presentation good morning good
afternoon thank you for a nice
introduction and at the same time very
welcome everyone to this webinar giving
details about pesticides explorer
collection it's a package focused on a
routine multi residue method for
determination of LC amenable pesticide
compounds using traditional catcher
sample preparation followed by different
instrumental patients
first I will give a short introduction
to pesticides era pesticides are
extensively used in agriculture to
protect crops from pests and improve
yields there are in use more than 1,000
different active substances with
different chemical properties and
various fields of application there are
various ways how they control the best
some of them are biodegradable however
some of them are persistent and can stay
in the environment for very long periods
difficult are thoroughly tested and
evaluated before approval and they are
all over the world resources regulated
but the problem occurs when the
pesticides are not applied in accordance
with the intended purposes and then the
guidelines for the correct application
are not followed in some countries the
most dangerous banned pesticides are
still used so then no wonder and because
of the high media publicity that there
is a significant public concern about
pesticide use the pesticides Explorer
collection is a comprehensive solution
for the analysis of pesticides in food
matrices it's a complete workflow
including sample preparation lcms
methodology and data processing it
complies this regulatory metrologic
recommended by the FDA USDA sanco and
the chinese gb standard testing it
offers a robust and treble solution
using both the triple quadrupole
platform and pugh e focus to demo
chemist cells and customers and it's
slowly start to finish work flow in this
slide you will find a short resume of
the four different bundles available
standard one for routine quantitation
with dsq endura second premium plan for
routine ultra sensitive quantitation
visit esq quant even so
earth high resolution a great mask one
for high-resolution quantitation using
the few key focus for high-resolution
Retina screen and grin using the Pew II
focus all bundles included in ultimate
3000 this 3400 RS pump attaches
extraction kit and the hplc combs needed
to run the recommended methods which are
also included a software kit including
trace finder is part of the grünberg
flows also in the screening where for
other software packages are included see
if compound this color and mass frontier
the high-resolution accurate mess
library is also included in all bundles
a user guide this is the customer on the
installation of the software at this
time we are not able to provide
standards as part of the bundle
collection however we will be happy to
assist the customer on locating and
ordering the different chemicals there
are many challenges which we have to
face during pesticide residue analysis
apart from the large amount of
pesticides and variety of different
matrices changes such as breakdown or
interaction of the pesticides metrics
binding and quality assurance can be
challenging it's required to a nice very
low levels of pesticides general maximum
residue limit is 10 ppb and the distinct
labs have to be able to analyze the
samples and provide the results as fast
as possible because the tested fruit of
them can be stored that a long time
let's have a look at some sample
preparation issues list by the stability
of most contaminants for some analyze a
poor recovery can be observed as the
temperature can play an important part
during the sample processing these
compounds interaction sensitivity than
not cooled during sample preparation it
is recommended either to reduce the
temperature with solid carbon dioxide
and perform the homogeneous ation of a
frozen sample in the picture is shown to
connect combination
in the process whereby the sample is
made a solid waste carbon dioxide and
homogenized in this slide is shown the
different of ambient and cryogenic
processing and what effect it has on the
recovery for some typical temperature
sensitive compounds the increase of
recovery by using cryogenic combination
is dramatic around fifty percent the
blue columns before the koechers method
was introduced sample preparation was
carried out typically by liquid liquid
extraction followed by clean up on gal
promotion chromatography or solid phase
extraction after which it was injected
on the detection system g CL C or GCMs
or lcms nowadays these techniques are
for pesticides analyzes mostly replaced
by catchers let's talk in more details
about this technique there are many
advantages of using catchers approach
the biggest benefit is its simplicity
almost any lab can do the analysis it
covers broad range of compounds ranging
from very polar compounds like some
organophosphates sside meta meta phors
for example to nonpolar compounds like
organochlorines the simple workflow
lowers the method costs and improve the
lab so put catches can be used either
with LC or GC determination step however
the green up step is rather limited only
dispersive spe can be employed it is not
suitable for l'espoir pesticides in
fatty foods and mainly with GC
determination some problems may occur
during acetonitrile injection for
example long term stability vapor
overflow and inland contamination also
the lifetime of the GC comb is
significantly reduced due to its huge
popularity and many benefits the
catchers approach was employed in our
method for expert connect collection the
mattress is tested for the Explorer
collections are strawberry representing
high voter and sugar content metrics
league as a complex and green vegetable
with high pigment content and floor
representing dry metrics this very low
flow water content the european version
of the kitchens extraction makes use of
10 gram of sample 10 milliliter of
acetonitrile sodium chloride magnesium
sulfate and citrate salts and is
recommended without any clean up the
final extract is an analyzed by lc-ms
without making use of disperses spe the
aoac version of this extraction makes
use of sodium acetate and is also
available to our customers please keep
in mind the different matrices may need
a different extraction approach and or a
cleanup step i will show you some
examples lighter pesticides explorer
includes a part numbers of all
consumables and chemicals which are
needed for pesticides analyzes you can
use either catches kiss this
pre-prepared extraction tubes containing
the needed sauce or you can go for most
more cost-effective options and order
the catches purchase here you can see
improving catches extraction tips and
tricks for some challenging matrices for
dry food with very low content of water
is recommended to add water to enable
adequate versioning and reducing
interaction of pesticides metrics the
production of heat is also reduced and
temperature sensitive compounds are
protected for food containing fat or vox
like avocado is recommended after
extraction to include a freezing out
step and employed the cleanup tube is
content of c18 additional cleanup might
be necessary for very complex analysis
st and spices for example very effective
is graphitized carbon
black which is used for removing the
pigments for mattresses with high
content acids can be helpful to adjust
ph to neutral values to increase
recovery and reduce by extraction of
metrics interferences the pesticides
experts plural contains also the
information about available catches
cleanup tubes you can learn more about
sample preparation from the ankles video
prepared by our experts in this field
pesticides explore collections will
contain also listed useful links and
other open sources with informational
that I related to this topic okay thank
you very much Katerina this is eddie
george i'm going to go ahead and proceed
with the presentation here talking a
little bit more about the methodology
employed in the pesticide explorer
collection and as you can see in this
slide here we show our triple quadruple
instruments on the left doing routine
quantitation and identification of
compounds that's most common in
laboratories today for these types of
pesticide analyses and basically we have
two instruments shown there we have a
tsq and dora and tsq quant eva and we
can do identification quantification and
of course reporting in that package has
done normally in laboratories for food
safety but we also offer a
high-resolution accurate mass solution
as well and with high resolution
accurate mass you can do screening and
identification of compounds that are not
necessarily part of a target compound
list so in traditional laboratories
oftentimes you have a large list of
compounds with transitions you input
them into a big long method and you run
a target analysis list with SRM and
basically in the high resolution
accurate
you can have a target list but you can
also look beyond that target list into a
screening type of mode for compounds
that you may not be expecting to be in
your samples so it offers laboratories
some increased flexibility in going
forward and looking for other compounds
that may be in the sample so the methods
in the pesticide Explorer collection for
the triple quadruple instruments are
included here in this slide and you'll
see here that there is a 15 minute and a
25 minute runtime LC method on the 15
minute method is more of a
high-throughput method and the 25-minute
method is more of a comprehensive larger
list pesticide method and the methods
are available on both platforms the
scanning mode that is used for these
particular triple quadrupole methods on
our timed SRM methods with polarity
switching occurring throughout the
entire run and as you can see the two
methods contain either a smaller 276
pesticide methods that's run in 15
minutes or a larger method run in 25
minutes containing about 440 compounds
in that particular method and the really
nice thing about this collection is that
the software that's included the trace
finder contains a master method as well
as an acquisition method so the complete
method is there and ready to load on
your instrument and so simply you set up
the conditions of the mobile phase and
inject the pesticide standards and you
will be often running on this method all
the methods use an active core AQ c18
column 100 x 2.1 with a 2.6 micron
particle which is a really good standard
column for these particular pesticides
and gives excellent peak shape for a
wide variety of polarities that are in
the methods the methods for the high
resolution accurate mass mass include
two methods there is a 15-minute high
throughput method also and then the 25
minute longer
on the QE focus platform and the scan
modes that are available our full scan
with data dependent m sms with polarity
switching and also another mode known as
a variable data independent acquisition
which is available in most parts of the
world except the u.s. in which you can
do a more overall arching overall
screening type view a full scan with m
sms occurring all the time in the
analysis and in both cases you get a
high resolution accurate mass library
and compound database which can be used
again to look for target compounds as
well as compounds that are beyond your
target compound list and the software
that's included again is trace finder
software with the master method and
what's really nice is that all methods
are using the same mobile phase and the
analytical column so if you are using
the triple quad solution you can
transfer the method to the high
resolution accurate mass instrument in
the same laboratory get the same
retention times and be on your way to
learning high resolution accurate mass
if you're new to this particular type of
analysis the extended or 25-minute
method as I mentioned earlier contains
440 pesticides on a 25 minute run and as
you can see picture to the right is a
illustration of the China GB standard
and most of the compounds that are
listed in this particular analysis cover
the European standards as well it's a 5
microliter injection and the complete
compound database and trace finder is
available it comes with the exit of the
Explorer collection package with the
instrument method and the trace finder
massive master method for processing the
data which again allows a user to set
this method up very rapidly in the
laboratory and this Hydra put 25 minute
method uses a gradient that's listed
here it's basically a water methanol
type gradient and we use a one
microliter injection in this particular
analysis for the high-throughput method
this allows less matrix to be
onto the system and we show here a flow
rate of three hundred microliters per
minute with a general runtime of 15
minutes and so this gives you a
relatively high throughput method
getting four samples completed in an
hour and again looking for 276
pesticides in the analysis so here's a
little bit of a close-up view of the
chromatogram in the high-throughput
method and you can see here we have
great peak shape for all the compounds
in the method as well as plenty of scan
points across the peak so the peak
widths are narrow and the instrument is
easily fast enough to give you plenty of
peaks for quantitation I'm what this is
based on one microliter injection and
the SRM lists the collision energy
retention times all that is figured out
for you it's in the trace finder
software and it's ready to go so this
makes it very easy for labs to set up
the methodology and really get going
because that's really what a lab needs
to do not spend a lot of time trying to
set up these methods and think about
what the SRM transitions are and so this
just shows an overall picture of the tsq
Endora API conditions as you can see
here we're using electrospray heute
electrospray generally spray voltage of
thirty seven hundred volts so these
particular settings were optimized for
this particular analysis and so what we
wanted to do was make sure that we were
able to meet the regulations and to
provide a method that is truly worthy of
being a compliant method in the next few
slides what you'll see here is the
validation of the Endura method so that
that way it shows the good
reproducibility and the types of data
that you can expect when you when you
look at the pesticide Explorer
collection package and with that I'll
hand it back over to Katerina thank you
at here's Katrina back and I will
continue in presentation and give you
more details about the validation of our
method
European Union guidelines for single
laboratory validation and pesticides
residue analysis were used to establish
method performance criteria including
linearity metrics effect LOD loq
precision and accuracy all metal
performance parameters were compared to
the relevant legislative requirements
and mr else for quantitative analysis
metrics match calibration was employed
and according to the legislation
description for compounds having more is
immersed only one values were
established the precision and finesse
was determined by the measurement of six
replicates of fortified samples at level
of 10 and 100 ppb above the accuracy was
that in mind for some compounds by
measurement of certified advanced
materials in the next slides details
about validation results will be given
however please be informed that duration
of this webinar is limited and
consequently the complete results cannot
be shown in all details a low key values
are always one of the most tricky issues
since the determination is not always
unambiguously described we have
established a low key values according
to the you buck signal-to-noise approach
since determination is often applied a
standard determination method in the
literature and well accepted among the
users the accept the acceptance criteria
was set for this calculation as loq less
or equal to mr else in the figure you
can see the pie chart showing the
percentage distribution of a lo puse for
strawberry metrics ninety percent of the
rules are under 1 PP be a percent of a
locus are from one to ten PBB and two
percent of compounds are above 10 ppb
llo q values fulfilled hours straight
area and are small or equal to mrs for
strawberry metrics similar figure but
showing the results for leak metrics you
can see here and the allergies
use our at average higher because of the
more complex metrics and more
interactions between the target
compounds and mattox part loq values
under one ppb are void for seventy six
percent of all target compounds twenty
two percent of focus our intervention
from one to 10 ppb and two percent of
compounds are above ten PPD but again
all ilocos fulfilled our criteria and
are smaller or equal to M models for
dick metrics and Plasmatics floor with
floor here the results are very similar
like four league metrics because floor
belongs to more complex matrices to a
low key values under one PPD where each
for seventy-five percent of all target
compounds twenty-two percent of fellow
cues are in the range from 1 to 10 ppb
and three percent of compounds are above
10 ppb again I'll all LLP values fulfill
our criteria in this slide you can see
the comparison of a low key values for
11 representative compounds for all
three matrices and solvent all values
are safely under the level of 10 PPD
which is a general maximum residual in
it for compounds and commodities were no
extra value you specified method recover
and repeat abilities are determined and
at two levels low and high 10 and 100
ppb for some compounds the values were
multiplied by two like for example for
DNA conazo because of the restricted
availability of standard mixtures for
each level of are prepared and and I six
replicates the low level of 10 ppb was
chosen as a general value for a model in
the table are shown the results for
recovery and repeatability for 12
representative compounds the acceptance
wrench for recovery both set from 70 to
100
twenty-five percent and all these chosen
compounds fulfill this requirement the
recovery results for lower level at 10
ppb are expressed in the graph under the
table a repeatability or more precisely
the method provisioned a precision was
established from recovery samples again
at two others 10 and 100 ppb and in six
replicates in the figure are shown the
results for lower level of 10 ppb for 12
representative compounds all values fall
in the range from zero to twenty percent
that was our criteria vision day
precision is demonstrated in this light
on the peak of varicose to be in the
right low corner you can see the
chromatograms overlay of repeated
measurements at low level this reached
value of our SD nine percent the
injection precision was determined by
the measurement of Tanner repeated
injections of standard mixture in
solvent at level of 100 ppb the
chromatograms over I is shown for
polakov strobing on the last finally the
method bias was tested with external
quality control materials for this
purpose for different four percent us as
last over of a lab proficiency test
samples were purchased and a nice for
the target compounds due to the limited
availability of QC materials the
purchase suppose materials that are
slightly different in matrix
Constitution from our target matrices
like this instead of League and Malone
pillar instead of strawberry the read
floor certified offense materials
available however only limited number
around four percent of target pesticides
represented in these samples despite of
a different metrics Constitution the
measured results showed very good
agreement with assign values or value
lying visions except the range as
results in the table demonstrate
the beaks is an external peak shape of a
nice pesticides in the quality control
material of weed floor and mounted I are
shown in this slide in next slide are
shown all product ions for example of
compounds determined in quality control
sample of lotus pm-1 quantified peak and
to confirm link ions qualifiers for the
metamorph are shown both is immersed
below in the next slide in next two
slides the examples of linear poble
calibration curves of some
representative pesticides are shown the
metrics match calibration was prepared
for each matrix from seven different
calibration points in the range from 0
to 100 ppb or from 0 to 200 PPD the
r-squared value for all calibration
curves we're below 0.98 5 here you can
see the calibration curve of formal tea
on and para kustra bean in all synthesis
here is the last example of chromatogram
of to pesticides acephate and Tia bandas
all in strawberry metrics showing the
peaks at a local level and corresponding
calibration curves so now it will
continue in the presentation okay thank
you Katerina for that great validation
data there what I'll talk about next is
looking at high resolution accurate mass
and how well that compares with the tsq
manure data so one of the concerns that
laboratories may have in moving to high
resolution accurate mass is indeed the
instrument sensitive enough to obtain
levels down to the guidance levels that
are required for monitoring and it turns
out if you look at this graph here at
the loq you can see that the tsq in dura
la choose conveyor very nicely with the
high resolution accurate mass QE focus
le cues hello cues and as you can see
there
out 200 the compounds are easily in the
one PBB range which is the majority of
compounds in the method and the
evaluation criteria is also very
important the percent difference in
terms of the calculated concentration
against the calibration curve needs to
be 80 to 120 percent with rsd is less
than or equal to fifteen percent for
seven replicates in each concentration
so it's a pretty strict type of guidance
there for the Ehlo jews as well as
having a mass accuracy of less than or
equal to 5 ppm so this really helps us
realize that high resolution accurate
mass in full scan can give us excellent
quantitation down to levels that are
comparable to the triple quadrupole
technology also calibration is very good
with high resolution accurate mass in
the full scan mode and you can see here
to pesticides where we look at the
accuracy and precision of seven
replicates at one part per billion with
accuracy easily 85 to 90 percent with
our SDS five to six percent and
coefficient of variations between six
and nine percent with excellent
linearity and so there's plenty of scans
across the peak for quantitation with
the orbitrap technology and plenty of
sensitivity as well and this is very
important for food labs that are looking
into high resolution accurate mass to be
able to get good confirmation and
quantitation and low concentrations in
the matrices that they are studying and
of course in this particular example we
show strawberry matrix here as an
example and so looking at the idea of
high resolution accurate mass in the
analysis of koecher's type samples you
can see that the high resolution
accurate mass solution has been used by
several universities to compare how well
the compounds and pesticides are
detected by high-resolution accurate
mass in a complex catchers extract and
then going on to doing data processing
to find these compounds and so the
University of almeria in Spain has done
a lot
Warner in comparing orbitrap technology
with triple quadrupole technology and
looking at detectability of the
pesticides based on various settings in
the mass spectrometer so in the next
slide we kind of take a look at that we
look at the importance of mass resolving
power for detecting pesticides in
complex matrices and as you can see here
on the graphs in the upper left-hand
corner we look at concentrations of
pesticides in a tomato matrix between 10
and 500 ppb and we look at the bars and
they represent resolutions of 17,500
35,000 and 70,000 and it turns out that
the orbitrap technology enables easily
resolution of 70,000 which is the
routine operating resolution in the QE
focus instrument as you can see the
number of pesticides detected increases
with increasing resolution and the
linearity generally improves also and
also the university found that the
relative standard deviation at 10 and
100 ppb also improves when the
resolution is better so there is a very
good relationship between mass resolving
power of the instrument and the number
of pesticides that you will detect with
confidence in the instrument and this is
shown to even a further extent when you
look at a more complex matrix like T as
you can see here at 10 parts per billion
the resolution of 70,000 gets close to
ninety five percent of the pesticides
detected and that's a very important
point because at lower concentrations
you want to have confidence that you're
able to detect the compounds at the
required resolution so that you will not
miss anything in the analysis and so
thats resolving power becomes a very
important factor when you consider high
resolution accurate mass in your
laboratory and so the other thing to
look at with high resolution accurate
mass is how well the mass accuracy is
maintained across a chromatographic peak
as you can see here a compound in
strawberry matrix and five micrograms
per kilogram maintains excellent mass
accuracy
approximately 2.2 ppm across the entire
range of that peak and the data
dependent ms2 analysis which is the
product line spectra obtained from this
peak also maintains excellent mass
accuracy in its particular mass spectrum
and so that gives the user very
excellent confidence that you're going
to get good quantitation as well as
confidence in identifying the compound
in a complex matrix and so here I talked
a little bit about the variable data
independent acquisition analysis and
basically this is a simplified
methodology for both quantitative
analysis and screening so the
quantitative analysis is done primarily
from the full scan data obtained and of
course the screening data allows you to
look for other compounds in full scan
you can look for compounds either during
the analysis or retrospectively and then
you can also confirm them with ms ms and
so what's great about this particular
mode is that no target list is acquired
and you're running full scan all the
time in the analysis at 70,000
resolution and your ms to spectra are
being obtained at 17,500 resolution and
what you essentially do is you break up
the mass range into specific segments
and then you do ms ms on those specific
segments and then the data system will
bring the m sms data and the full scan
data together to help give you both a
quantitative analysis with the full scan
data and also confirmation with the m
sms data and so it's a very powerful
technique that you can use to look for
compounds that go beyond your target
compound list and a lot of laboratories
today are required to do this because in
the importance of food safety we need to
know what else might be in that sample
that may be lurking out there that's not
in our target compound list that would
never be detected in with triple
quadrupole technology and so here's an
example of confirmation with this VD I a
scan mode and as you can see it kind of
looks like a triple quadrupole you can
have a quantitation peak and then
several Peaks you can choose full
our qualitative ions and doing iron
ratio experiments just like you would in
a triple quad and usually you can see
here this is the confirmation of AZ axis
drill then down at one part per billion
you're getting plenty of signal at one p
BB you're getting an excellent
calibration curve and you can do
fragment pattern matching in the
software as it's available for the
analysis and so this scan mode again is
available pretty much globally except
for in the US and it's a very powerful
scan mode that's available in the
instrument and so for high-resolution
accurate mass we think about
confirmation techniques that we can use
every day in the laboratory to help us
give us confidence in our data and so
obviously the first kind of experiment
that you'll do is you'll do a mass
extraction window so you want excellent
mass accuracy say less than 5 part per
million and you want to obtain that on a
routine basis and with the orbit trap
technologies the mass resolution the
mass resolution and sensitivity is a
excellently is basically maintained very
well because you don't need to do a lock
mass calibration it's very stable and
stable for a very long time so that mass
extraction window becomes a very
important confirmation technique and
eliminating your background matrix then
of course you can look at isotope
pattern matching and use that as a way
to help you identify the compound the
third ways look at fragment search if
you have em SMS data from full scan data
dependent ms to or VDI a scan modes you
can look at fragment searching results
to give you identification and then
finally a very important aspect that i
want to talk a little bit more about its
high resolution accurate mass library
searches that you can do from the data
and that's what's really nice is that
you will actually have a full scan
product nine spectrum which you can use
to do a library search and get more
confidence in your result and so what
we've done is we built some high
resolution pak-rat mass m sms spectral
libraries and compound databases as you
can see here in this particular database
for environmental food safety we have
over 1600 compounds that are basically
individual compound spectra and
basically these are great for
confirmation of results so it's kind of
nice here is that you can have a target
compound list in your high resolution
accurate mass and then you then you can
go off and search this database for
other compounds that may not be on your
target list and so it's a very effective
way of screening the sample for a lot of
compounds very rapidly and what we're
doing here is we're increasing the
number of spectra all the time in what
we call a thermo fisher MZ cloud
approach which I'll talk a little bit
about in a later slide which is a way to
help improve and increase the number of
spectra that are available for library
searches and so when you think about a
high-resolution accurate math library
there are really three things here that
give you a really nice advantage first
is high confidence and compound
identification because you want to
minimize false positives and false
negatives as well as eliminate matrix
interferences secondly it's an
off-the-shelf database so therefore it
reduces method development time and
saves you costs as a laboratory and then
finally the library feature is
customizable so that new compounds in
spectra maybe add to the library at any
time and so you may want to set up your
own library with your own scanning
conditions going forward and so these
libraries are easily loaded into trays
finder software and what's nice is you
can load in the high resolution accurate
mass library that I proposed earlier as
well as other libraries that are
available that you can bring into the
library search locally on your computer
and then run those libraries and use
them against your data and the other
thing I wanted to mention was that not
only do we have the high resolution
accurate mass spectra library where we
all but we also have a compound database
and the compound database corresponds to
the library so in the m sms spectra
library as i mentioned before we have
1600 compounds but these 1600 compounds
contain spectra from five to six
different energy
so in the end at the end of the day the
MSM a spectra library contains about
seven to eight thousand spectra however
the fragments and all the other metadata
that go on with those compounds are
present in these high-resolution
accurate mass compound databases and
these databases are very important again
to help you identify compounds and what
we've done here is we based this
compound database on retention times in
the extended 25-minute method so the
laboratory wants to set up a very quick
screening method they would set up the
mobile phase and conditions or the
pesticides that we use in the extended
method and then this database would
correspond to the retention times in
that method and that way you would have
accurate mass as well as fragments and
retention time to help you identify the
compound of interest and again it
doesn't have to be on your compound list
and that's what makes this method very
very powerful for going beyond and
looking at other compounds in a sample
so here's an example of a library search
result for boss Khalid it shows that
mass accuracy and sensitivity are not
compromised on orbitrap technology and
that's very very important but low
concentrations you still obtain a high
qualities mass spectrum to which then
you can get a library search result with
a high score and so that's really
important and as I mentioned earlier
that high resolution ability of the
instrument is very important in high
resolution accurate mass technology
instruments MZ clouds I mentioned before
is a is a basic it's basically a
cloud-based web based server and it's a
collaboration between not only thermo
fisher scientific but other
collaborators the donate spectra it's a
very very comprehensive type of database
and so if you go to MZ cloud there's a
lot of different metadata there there's
a lot of different spectral trees you
know going to ms to the end and a lot of
cases and the idea is to use MZ cloud as
a future repository for spectra and then
in future versions of trace binder give
one the ability to download these
to local databases to increase their
particular database size and so this
will be thermo fisher's way of
increasing library sizes making more
compounds available to the users and
really giving you the utmost in a
comprehensive library going forward and
so if you're interested go ahead and
visit this site take a look at it it has
a lot of information and it'll probably
overwhelm you but it's really quite
quite a nice collection of spectra and
so just in review i'll look at the
pesticide explorer collection in terms
of the software package that comes with
this little collection so of them as we
mentioned early in the slide
presentation here we have a quantitation
package that's available for both the
high-resolution accurate mass and the
triple quad platforms and it includes in
software the trace finder version 3.2
along with the high resolution accurate
mass m sms spectre library if you decide
to have the QE focus instrument along
with a USB stick that contains all the
method and user guides to make it very
easy for the lab to set up the analysis
and so it's a start-to-finish workflow
everything is there and ready to go and
also we have the screening and
quantitation package and that goes
beyond just the standard mrm types of
analysis or even quan with a high
resolution accurate mass and so that has
other software tools to help you look at
other other compounds it might be in
your sample in a retrospective way such
as compound Discoverer and mass frontier
as well as sieve which helps you do pca
analysis for looking at comparisons
between different sample types and
trying to understand differences in
samples so a very powerful suite of
software to really let you dig in and
analyze high-resolution acrobat data and
again these methods are available on the
USB stick and the user guide really
helps especially new users set up high
resolution accurate mass in a very rapid
way and that's really important because
a lot of laboratories are new to high
resolution accurate mass and will
definitely need some help to get used to
the tech now
and so I'd like to thank the
contributors to this particular
pesticide explorer collection a lot of
work went into this from a lot of our
colleagues and when I thank them for
giving us a really good package here
it's a really dynamic package very easy
to set up and very easy for laboratories
to get going and with that I want to
thank you for your attention during this
webinar and if there are if there are
any questions you can simply contact us
here I list a bunch of emails you can
email any one of us it would be glad to
get back to you with more information
about the collection and about how you
can get it for your laboratory and with
that I want to thank you very much and
with and thermo fisher scientific
obviously as a global reach we're pretty
much everywhere in the world but you can
think of thank you for your attention q
for that informative presentation before
we start with our question and answer
session I want to remind our audience
how to submit their questions you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button on the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to answer as many of your
questions as we can please note that Ed
George will not be available during this
Q&A session but Caterina has agreed to
feel all of your questions and our first
question from our audience member is in
our queue now how does the peak shape of
the early eluding pesticides look like
for example the SFA or corner quoi
katrina could you answer that question
good morning good afternoon here is
Katrina yes I'm happy to answer this
question yes actually thanks to very low
injection volume only one microliter he
has very good pic shape even for this
very early losers we made some tests and
with high injection volumes like three
microliter the pig's birthday link and
the big shape was unacceptable but
this one microliter everything is fine
great thank you we do have another
question were the values of loq under
the ml m RL levels for the compounds
which have mrl higher than 10 ppb yes
yes our a low Q values for all three
matrices for which we validated our
method and we tested our method loq
swear under levels of stipulated a model
values great thank you we do have
another question could you tell me which
instrument is more sensitive the triple
quadrupole or the HR am ok in this
presentation we were talking about to
actually more methods for two triple
quadrupole tsq andorra and PS q grant
Eva which is high-end instrument and
high resolution occurred mass
spectrometer you exactly focus and Q
executive so if shall I compare tisk you
andorra triple quadrupole and Q exactly
focus or Q executive here the
sensitivity is comparable tisk you want
eva is a little bit more sensitive we
can say roughly 10 times more sensitive
than the SQ andorra I hope the dice
answer the question correctly great
thank you for that we do have another
question what would you personally
recommend as a method for hram
instrument media or DD full scan which
one do you prefer ok here i personally
prefer the usage of v dia because you
don't need to know the precursors and
set it for the confirmations however at
this moment this method can be used in
yes but in Europe there's there are no
restrictions so I'm definitely for vdi
great thank you for that answer I just
want to see if our audience has any more
questions I wanted to let me know we do
have Catalina here to answer any
questions that you have about today's
presentation and we'll just give that
another minute see if we have any of our
attendees who would have questions and I
don't see any in the incoming Q&A I'd
like to just turn it back to Katerina
now for any final comments or thoughts
that she has for the audience on today's
presentation so I think we are becoming
too one more question am i right oh let
me see we have that and I don't see any
are any interior what categories of
substances interfere with accurate
analyses with this equipment and methods
okay I think it can be more type of
substances for instance some pigments in
league especially or or some assets
because we are using for sample
preparation catchers and this method is
very fast you to use about and we don't
use clean up the extract final extract
is not so clean so there can be really
some interferences but thanks to using
triple quadruple or high resolution a
spectrometer for determination they
should not interfere there should not be
big problems with Center fences great
thank you for that we do have a discount
from our audience joy with you tonight
saying presentation is excellent thank
you for that and we would like to take
any more of your questions if you have
them for us can I mean I here to answer
those things I don't see any in the text
Caterine maybe you want to um yeah maybe
I've I would like to just thank you the
audience for listening to our webinar
and I hope that it will be helpful for
you for your routine work in the labs
and if you have any questions please
contact us we will be very happy to help
you thank you thank you katrina for
spending time with us today in bringing
us is presentation i would also like to
thank our sponsors Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May of 2016 and you'll receive an email
from laggards alerting you man this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcements
your colleagues may have missed today's
live event that's all we have for today
thank you for joining us